well it's a 1-minute tournament warzone
rated 109 players at this point average
rating 1767 time handicapped time will
be adjusted according to player's
ratings in order to try and balance
things out and 30-minute tournament okay
experience level none anybody could play
here we go
fire spawn let's go fishing poles
oh the nights are getting kicked away
get out of there night uh-oh
does he gonna go home is the night gonna
go home no no he is not have five coming
up get out of there
I'm gonna push again or am I
oh they resigned they're getting kicked
around too much I guess they got nervous
Oh give me your queen
he has three points already how does
this guy have three points give me a
clean as three points to try the Alpen
variation sometimes c3 I would
definitely have a bit more variety -
okay so we're not entering that are we
no no we are not Queen h4 let's back up
am I not gonna get kicked away okay I
have this covered don't do I not okay
I'm still gonna run with this f5 gonna
be a queen check
I could always back my bishop up to
defend let me do this right now and
let's do this okay so my attention is
actually gonna be in this direction I'm
gonna go here because the a file could
open up at any second and I think
bringing my Queen back is a good idea
I'm on that pond I should have taken it
I'm gonna take it now and then maybe
kick that bishop away control beef
what's happening with that oh that was
just a slip-up right get that night out
of there
if the rook land for kit the Queen they
hear rooks off the board no there isn't
there's a pin right here oh I should
have landing a flat at a fork she did
that instead of taking on a 8 ok anyhow
I'm up to the clean and to keep
everything connected actually the Queen
is running out of squares Queen trade
coming up ah what's happening
give me your clean lost the Queen and
why'd I do that
ok might be an in-between move there
alright no no no could have been bad
that could have been bad news right
there free moves kill f6 ok they're down
a time 644 I have a two-point lead ok
double those points c5 and you know
what's coming seen it before see it
again or will be no way it can't happen
again
can it they're gonna go Queen side and
say no ok they're going Queen side
alright so let's do this instead d6
connect my Knights stop g4 stop g4 and
go to g3 with my knight connect here
first they're gonna go after this pawn
let's do this I think I could actually
okay I'm gonna do this I should be okay
I'm gonna recapture with my pawn here I
need a little shelter for my King and
inside castle oh no no no hit the Queen
this is a tough spot to be in here isn't
it take this and then do that looking
for me in some way pawn push also pawn
push here actually or here
Oh what's happening here stay
coordinated right here I still have my
sights on that situ pond on the night
hit the Queen Bishop coming out with
check grab this pond as well I think
this is brutal
uh-oh now why did I do that I thought
that I know okay give a check but my
king up I shouldn't actually just
castled let's come here before it's too
late
that was a bad idea very very bad idea
to move my king like that should the
queenside castle okay let's do this
there's no time though back back
determine 1276 a lot of time a lot of
time left in this one okay I think these
are some new opponents that I'm playing
against f4 f4 Knight f3 d4 mm-hmm kick
that night away and I'm gonna actually
give up my seat pond and then do what
okay that that was probably a good idea
okay fishing time to go fish the Knights
actually there never mind I'll recapture
like this and there's Queen check but I
don't know if that's really a great idea
okay let's get castled and then throw a
rock we're right here
oh the Queen's dead resignation or not
pawn push
okay everything's coming off now and
just open up the position g7 is where I
want to be million to no matter what
can't be defended time Bernie uh nope
back to tournament 2020 who has twenty
toner avec has four games in as well
okay somebody is right there let's go
okay so what's this closest Cillian okay
actually read this recently let's try
this right now get out of there Bishop
make a decision okay mmm I played this
wrong I should I should just take in
that pond but wait there's I don't I
don't need to castle now I definitely
don't need to castle let me get this
night can I get rid of them I'm gonna
queenside castle actually I'm gonna do
this and then queenside castle it's a
little scary but I'm gonna do it tonight
right here next I'm on the knight twice
this is a serious problem there's it's
gotta be sacrifices no no let's break
this open actually what's that what's
happening here
if you grab that night next I can grab
it twice even that the bishop comes here
Queen check I'm on the knight twice and
Bishop just a couple of King moves to
sidestep checks oh there's a knight
check right there there would have been
a knight check I think it would still be
alright somehow I have this pair of
pawns right here quite strong and these
guys are not developed yet oh but I
should have seen that I should have did
King here okay dark square this
diagonals opened up another reason to go
with this particular pond move and I
think just to give a check they might
miss the lateral movement or not pawn
push
actually let's just defend they have no
time okay I'm gonna do this and then
just push my pawn to Kunene no time no
time back to tournament 3130 who's this
guy
this guy's probably ready to win or is
he gonna fry plenty gets known to fry
Nona fries here we go let's see what's
gonna happen
on the Friday no okay wait now I could
do this move that Bishop there could be
a fork at any moment here we go
castle Queenie one I'm gonna do this
actually let's let's expand my bishop
could be shut down I'll try and break it
see for if that happens I want to do
this just so I could be assured that my
bishop will be able to see the world
wants to see the world and let's come
here Bishop here rook to d1 is the plan
this pond is unprotected okay now this
pond is accessible I don't want to take
it just yet I want to get rid of this
Bishop I don't think this guy is gonna
go anywhere this pond now I'm gonna take
it check and then post my knight right
here looking for a fork I don't know if
I really have anything exciting I'm
gonna play back here pin maybe a fork
next that's defended good defense there
okay let's stop that Knight from doing
anything how much time they have and
they have a time edge still owe Knight
right here so much for that castle we
get my other night doing something right
okay I'm setting up like some back rank
stuff I'm okay with that Knight being
taken double pawns I want my knight on
g6 okay knight on g6 coming up forks
hitting the rook I want to hit okay this
and I want to get to h8 if the rook
leaves the back rank there's trouble
let's come over here chase the night
away it's not being chased away actually
I think I have it I think I have it if
the rook takes the pawn pin the knight
and then play here and then there's main
what is that move looking for mate again
this move paved the way awhile back
that's why I did it you get these pawns
the rook can not leave it can't leave
the back rank they have to take the
knight time situation
time time time how much time surround I
came back to term at the data time 61 42
who's this guy up here
TF corrupt somebody has 61 19 minutes
and change I gotta hunt that person down
I got a hunt now I'm going hunting I'm
going fishing it's the same old
recording isn't it
same old recording uh-oh it's being
launched it's being launched is being
launched it's officially launched h3
does not defend okay that was the best
defense okay I got excited there here we
go the white squares are weakened we can
light squares
get out of there bishop okay let's do
this okay I'm gonna go up my queen
actually dark squares check pawn push
not so fast though okay yes fast oh
that's just a free Queen they meant
maybe Queen to f2 let's come back here
oh I should have given a check
deflection I should have done that I
would have won the rook let's try this
now Knights pinned get my Bishop out
here check the knight can't move my
queen is close to trapped packet come
out in this way check I'm hitting this
guy next the rook these bishops are
brutal the rook is getting sliced up
here uh-oh might be a bishop check but
that's it
okay I gotta get this quicker though
let's go
cannot let my clock tick in a position
like this no way just do that no matter
what right here this no matter what this
no matter what this no matter what I'll
push no matter what give a check don't
let my clock tick at me real close back
determined forfeit on time 79 56 that
purse has nine games in
let's go here and come on I gotta track
that guy down going huntin okay
d5 is weak oh there's gonna be a pin no
there's not
there still might be but the light
squares weakened mmm okay all right that
night needs to go somewhere else now
Queen don't you dare
okay I'm okay with them oh wait wait I
got the Queen resignation time I'm gonna
take my knight B file next get this
right here open this up open it up Queen
here check oh I'm on the rook let me go
here with check and then take the rook
whit's check or not okay close to me
very very close to me and I'm just gonna
take that get this pawn or not just take
this this is check breaking this open
here that's me that's me that was fairly
quick back to tournament 79 72 he's
ready to win though I'm sure he's ready
to win okay we could get paired up 15
minutes and change before this
tournament is over okay so there's
definitely time to catch but I am
needing to make sure I win all these
games in the meantime where is that
night going where is he going what is he
up to
let's try this oh man I have to take
like this otherwise Knight f5 okay let's
do this space advantage let's come here
defend that there might be a pawn push
yeah I should have done that they take
this and then do this and then watch
over this I guess it's gonna get hit my
LightSquared bishop wants to be
somewhere else get out oh no no no no no
no no no no no no I didn't see the
threat Oh scary time scary time oh man
oh man bishop takes or something is
there gonna be bishop takes or something
oh man oh man oh man oh man oh man I'm
really scared
uh-oh Oh Oh save the day ruck
save the day Oh
the Queen's dead Oh they slipped up they
were getting nervous
the Knights falling oh they're crumbling
crumbling crumbling time take this guy
oh man
that's me look at all the tables turn in
just one move 97-90 be prepared don't be
scared
let's go let's go let's go let's go ah
the great one one one the great one I'm
playing against okay let's try this
fishing pole it's preparing for a
fishing pole actually prepping one
ingredient Oh
that's the anti fishing pole all right
well let's go with a different setup
then defend this oh wait wait wait this
is sort of similar to um who did I play
against - what's his name what's his
name what's his name party rock party
rock the party rock game that's a party
rockin okay c6 is weakened in other
words with that b6 move I could be
playing this and then pivot my pieces on
this c6 square that's somebody looking
to do I'm dropping this pawn why did I
drop a pawn okay let's come over here
pawn push okay let's do that
how do I get to this square now can I
make that happen
let me grab this pawn for starters just
for starters might be counter sack I'm
gonna back up actually if that happens
let's do this there's no quick kill
though why am i playing like this I
should be looking for um the Kings throw
and I'm not doing that okay let's take
that first and then the knight and then
the pond and then this right here I'm on
the night I could give a check get that
night out of there
maybe okay let's do this
um I just want to take that night Oh
what's going on here a little scary
Queen right here sneaky sneaky moves be
prepared for him uh-oh sneaky moves
coming up check brutal the queen is dead
soon she is dead
no time okay I'm just pre moving stuff
no pre move stuff no time back to
tournament 125 come on
what's going on 125 110 I gotta get this
guy Andy French all right um
104 103 what's the queen doing she's
being sneaky right there in situ she's
uh she having fun right there in that
little pocket I'm gonna try a gambit I
guess that was actually a mouse slip
turned into gambit God the pond and come
back is the plan here fish it back here
it's very difficult to get anything
going okay well actually maybe I could
still get I still have vague thoughts of
the fishing pole bishop here I was think
about taking first but I shouldn't I
should do a fork right away queenside
castle open this up maybe g5 actually
g5g for keep that night away if I do
this the night house this square let's
try this I'm gonna take with the pawn
otherwise I dropped this okay G file
where's that Nyko now the dark squares
i/o I'm gonna do this King King problems
over here okay I'm just getting material
now it's that pond gonna be taken it's
bad news if that happens right here main
ting to threat
okay let's support this still making two
or three something close
that's matin one can't be avoided
actually a night check is the only thing
that's mate next no time no time back to
terminal 1:30 1:45 1:30 15 points out
ten minutes and change it snappy it's
not easy here Claus for you okay let's
get this in oh there goes my light
square bishop my good guy right there my
good guy here we go H pawn you could do
it dark squares right here pins pins
pins pins let's go for the pins here
let's go here f6 is where I want to be
with my pieces now let's not do that
okay I want to push here that Bishop
might have to go back home what's
happening here
okay I'm dropping stuff okay I still
want to get to this square though these
two squares dark squares I got here I'm
getting here I got here and I'm getting
here check and kick this away actually
Knight takes here I think is a good one
that King is gonna be flushed out though
if the knight moves I have made I'm
gonna be sneaky if the knight place here
I'm gonna push if a knight takes Knight
Queen d6 Maine anything actually a
bishop here would be sufficient for me
Queen here is good too maybe something
tells me the right be like in a slower
game this could be calculated somehow
the King running out crazy in the center
takes takes takes takes takes King a
bunch of Knights a captured in like
three or four moves oh they're just
letting the clock tick
it better be their clock that's ticking
I might do primo heh is to burn their
time there's no good solution here I
guess they're just a clock burner clock
burnin better give me the points aw they
have to check the server oh they have to
go and have to do a countdown this is
brutal
it's not enough to just have their clock
out they have to check confirmed things
yes the server says game over I get 20
165 158 minutes and change that guy has
16 games in Who am I playing okay the
granola bar against the granola bar this
is my best friend right here it's my
best friend I don't want to beat my best
friend
I do i and I shouldn't have done that
right now I can get that dark square
bishop I'm gonna take him pinpoint the
dark squares pinpoint it pinpoint it
uh-oh I got that pawn dark squares
everywhere check and let me I was ready
just pushed that pawn let's not do that
let's come here and then here I just
want to get to this Square please let my
bishop get right here everything will be
wonderful okay everything's wonderful
okay there's nothing that I'm my
opponent could do I have a strong grip
on the position pawn push a couple times
I'm gonna do with tempo I'm on the night
they're gonna be sacrificed right here
there might be sacrifice right here ah
no no there's not there would have been
maybe actually because I was in trouble
okay I'm lending material oh I almost
mouse slipped you see how that rook
stuttered right there
Oh grab this pond light-square
weaknesses open this position up Oh
Bishop's are everywhere the queen is
dead design-time don't have any time
this is check back up look for mate next
name - al one H - back to term at 185
170 I can't overcome this these fifteen
points seven minutes seven minutes let's
go here
Scandinavian okay tempos tempos tempos
tempos Bishop here stop that okay let's
do something crazy okay we're doing
something crazy right now
post up that night right here gonna take
that night queenside castle let me have
that
how many mouse slips can you make in one
game okay the bishop is gonna give me a
check that's kind of not good man
okay what's the okay artificially
castled here I guess and let's do this
and let's do wow this is very scared
look at all these minor fees I don't
know how to make sense of it okay oh
okay I gotta come back here I'm on that
bishop after this if this pin is
resolved I want to get it resolved real
soon - then I can't move just yet I'm
gonna take like this and the bishops
dead actually if that if the night isn't
grabbed okay oh it's dead it's a dead
bishop
dead bishop it's a dead man yes okay
come on these aren't quick wins though I
need a one quick win or two one or two
okay let me do this there's gonna be a
check or something isn't there let's get
my knight back over here what's the time
situation let's go take like this and
then rook f6 or something I'm gonna be a
take no okay h4 h5 everything is
defended now it could be a clean trade
at any moment I want to weaken that Jeep
on weekend the Jeep on get to f6 look
for made on g7 cleans have to come out
like right now they're not half and it's
mate and a couple okay back to the
tournament what - twenty five thirty
five point lead I need quick resign errs
where the quick resign errs where are
they let's go and now I should have done
c5 okay maybe you could still get this
the crouching Queen variation come on do
this actually I'm gonna try this see if
my opponent does now
uh-oh
Oh these pawns are getting launched
launching pawns castle coming up connect
these Knights queenside castle pawn push
I'm gonna castle anyhow a little scary
actually we did this forks forks
everywhere that was scary
pawn push okay discover dumb tricks
against the Queen
real soon oh the Queen is gonna play
here I'm on the Queen it might be missed
pawn push next I'm on the Queen resign I
really need a resignation quick I'm on
the bishop everything's falling I'm on
the night everything's falling I'm not
getting made at Mi oh no way no I'm not
okay I have this block the bishop could
give a check though huh I'm dead man no
no oh I couldn't take in the rook what
am i doing oh it was a free rope ah that
there's a free night everything is free
and look at this position everything is
free everything's for sale
ah the rook the knight the bishop there
could have been a brutal check here's
another free piece you name it it's free
if you name it it's free what am i
dealing with that move now the bishops
gonna give a check and then this is
falling let me do this I need time
burners time burners my knight is dead
Wow where do my pieces go I get one back
I might get one back I got a rookie okay
finally it's coming together here okay
let's go here gobble gobble gobble push
push push
and this was not quick at all we have
time tick what's the count
what's the count - ten - what - 65 I
need four wins in a row where are those
quick resign as quick resigner this is a
quick resigner come on let me get that
first-place confetti ah yeah it's back
to tournament you see there we go 265
230 quick resigner GM knight quick
resigner mmm
quick resigner quick resigner that's all
I have
that's all I have if the Queen push-up
on don't be sneaky okay she's not being
sneaky oh okay I'm gonna push her around
a little bit they're going Queen side I
could feel it Queen side it is all right
Queen out here mmm I can't really do
that I wanted to do that but I really
can't do that let's go this side pawn
push I don't want to clean trade all
right give me the beef I'll be file be
file one minute 37 it's not happening
there's no way is there no I can't deal
with the Queen trade get the Queen okay
push that and then push that the queen
is getting kicked around quite a bit
mates right move my knight next this has
got to be a killer that's me no it's not
get out of there night you can't be
sitting there okay this is a win but
come on I don't have any time I was just
trying to move my knight can you believe
that do not move that Knight do this
interfere with the coordination on that
then do this then take the bishop then
give me in-betweener this is a command
can I get two more wins in somehow this
one and one more there's only 42 seconds
left
ah deflection get rid of that bishop I
want to get @b to being sneaky what do
we have 23 seconds they didn't even let
me finish that game there was more time
I thought ah man how many games that guy
have 23 games even if I won that one
right there 16 I had in which is still a
pretty pretty good amount right there
good games oh man